Es ist absolut erschreckend und ein warnruf wir essen unmengen nico plastik eine britische forschungsgruppe hat per zufall die menge heraus gefunden
und sie ist exorbitant wirklicher wahnsinn demnach essen wir jedes jahr
70.000 micro
Plastikteilchen eine wirklich irrwitzige menge und wahrscheinlich ist es noch viel mehr das unglaubliche problem mit dem mikro plastik und warum es
Dramatische ausmaße annimmt jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja es ist ja eine wirklich dramatische entwicklung mit dem mikro plastik es ist in so vielen produkten wie zahnpasta oder
Kosmetikartikel und es wird immer mehr durch das zerreiben des plastikmülls erzeugt und das absolut erschreckende. Im meer ist es verschwunden
ein absolutes horror-szenario laut dem fünfjahres institut schwimmen in den weltmeeren
269.000 tonnen plastikmüll das sind rund
38.500
müllwagen ladung und das ist nur der müll der oben schwimmt das ist nicht nur eine ziemlich schlimme sauerei
sondern auch eine üble verseuchung der umwelt viele denken bei plastikmüll an
hässliche tüten flaschen styropor folien und so weiter
das ist schön und auch daran sterben tiere die sich darin verfangen und qualvoll verhungern und
Oder ersticken aber das ist nur die spitze des eisbergs das team um den forscher
Marcus ericsson hat um die müllmenge genauer zu bestimmen die daten aus 24 untersuchungen mit
1500 sammlungen und beobachtungen zusammen getragen und ist so auf diese hohe menge gekommen dabei ist die anzahl der tonnen
Noch nicht mal so hoch wenn man die zahl der plastikteilchen hört es sind fünf millionen teilchen sprich
5000 milliarden
Plastikteilchen die in unseren ozean schwimmen eine absolut erschreckende zahl viel schlimmer ist aber das was die forscher nicht
gefunden haben die menge der plastikteile mit der größe eines sandkorn zwar
100 mal geringer als vermutet und das ist ein ganz schlechtes zeichen es gibt zwei möglichkeiten die zeichen gelangen in tiefere, wasserschichten
oder und das ist ein wirkliches horrorszenario werden in riesigen mengen von fischen gegessen und das ist ja auch inzwischen x-fach bestätigt worden
Das mikro plastik ist über alle mehr aber nicht nur da das hat jetzt eine neue studie
Herausgefunden in jeder mahlzeit die wir zu uns nehmen sind rund 100 mikro plastikteilchen aber woher kommen die teilchen und jetzt wird es wirklich
Spooky sie kommen aus der luft bot das forschungsteam
Um ted henry von der harry potter university in edinburgh untersuchte dazu wieviel micro
plastikteilchen während einer mahlzeit aus der luft auf dem teller landen dazu wurden petrischalen mit einer klebrigen substanz
Aufgestellt, um die menge während einer mahlzeit. Zu zählen die aus der luft auf dem teller landet es waren und jetzt festhalten
100 und damit sind das
70.000 im jahr pro mensch zitat wer bisher annahmen dass der anteil an plastik fasern in meeresfrüchten
Höher sei als im durchschnittlichen hausstaub für den sind diese ergebnisse?
Überraschend wir wissen nicht woher all diese fasern genau kommen außer dass er sich
Im haus befinden so der studienautor
Ted henry hier mal eine aufnahme aus meiner wohnung
So viel staub sammelt sich hier in berlin in rund fünf tagen und offenbar ist das nicht nur staub sondern auch eine menge micro plastik
absolut erschreckend und die gesundheitlichen konsequenzen sind heute noch gar nicht abzusehen an den plastikteilchen haften chemikalien
und mikroben an die sich dann
im menschen
anreichern
Beziehungsweise so überhaupt erst in uns gelangt wenn er als erstes neues zum thema micro plastik und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genauen blogger vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
Draufklicken wir essen classic da ging es nur um die verschmutzung in den meeren ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran